If you go and look up a photo of a boxer from
the 19th century, it’s almost certain that
the individual will be standing like the gentlemen
pictured right.
While it may look a little silly to modern
fans of the sport, this was actually a very
effective fighting stance for those wishing
to win a 19th century boxing match.
For anyone unfamiliar, the reason this old
timey, once ubiquitous, “fisticuffs stance”
is so mocked or derided by fans of the sport
today is for the glaring weaknesses inherent
to it, namely that the boxer stands with their
hands low and their chin up- a great way to
get your head pummeled.
While it’s certainly true that a person
utilising the fisticuffs stance would be in
trouble in a modern day boxing match, a modern
boxer would likely be in just as much trouble
sparring off against a pugilistic champ from
the golden age of boxing, if they boxed by
the rules of the period.
As for why, most pertinent here is the fact
that neither boxer would be wearing gloves
in such a classic match.
As paradoxical as it’s going to sound, boxing
without gloves is actually widely considered
to be safer than boxing with them, among other
reasons because bare knuckle boxers rarely
punched one another in the head with full
force, so the risk of brain injury or knockout
was dramatically lower.
You see, lacking protective hand gear, punching
someone in the head with every ounce of your
physical might is a great way to very seriously
injury your hands, particularly when done
repeatedly.
Combine this with the fact that many 19th
century boxers sometimes competed multiple
times per week and that there were no time
limits for many old timey bouts (one match
in 1893 even went 111 rounds, see Bonus Facts
below), and you begin to see why protecting
the head wasn’t as much of a concern as
it is today.
While blows to the head did happen, particularly
if a clean shot to the cheek could be had,
the head tended not to be the focus.
(This aversion to headshots is believed to
be one of the reasons so many old timey pugilists
were able to compete so frequently and keep
boxing for upwards of three decades in some
cases, all the while maintaining their mental
faculties well into old age.)
So that explains why the stance doesn’t
have the hands more directly protecting the
head like today, but why the specific hand
position of left arm out and right arm tucked?
Among other benefits, this is partially linked
to another, often overlooked rule of early
boxing bouts.
Prior to the Queensbury rules officially introduced
in the 1860s and proliferating from there,
the rules of specific prize fights between
pugilists varied, but invariably allowed grappling.
As an example of how things were before more
civilised competitions, in 1713, Sir Thomas
Parkyns described a typical boxing match as
including eye-gouging, choking, punching,
head-butting and other such street fighting
tactics.
This all changed when Jack Broughton developed
the first set of formalized rules for boxing
in 1743.
The impetus for these rules came, in part,
from Broughton’s defeat of George Stevenson,
who suffered severe injuries and died a few
days after the pair’s fight.
Saddened by the death of his competitor, Broughton
wrote the “Broughton Rules” to minimize
the harsher aspects of the sport, like forbidding
striking below the belt, not allowing hitting
a competitor when he was down and giving him
30 seconds to recover and continue the fight,
lest he be declared the loser.
However, one thing Broughton’s rules did
allow was the aforementioned grappling.
tn_mcgovern1902As a result, the boxing stance
of the era emphasized keeping distance between
yourself and your opponent, usually with both
arms outstretched.
Later, thanks to an individual we’ll talk
about shortly, it switched to just keeping
your left hand outstretched.
This not only made for a potential minor offensive
weapon your opponent had to worry about if
they tried to come in close, but also was
great for teasing out and defending against
jabs and glancing blows from a distance.
The tucked right (dominant for most) hand
being held close helped defend against counter
hooks and body blows when your opponent managed
to get past your left arm.
And, of course, the arm was cocked and ready
to deliver more powerful blows.
Keeping both arms tucked would simply allow
your opponent too easy grappling access to
your main trunk.
As for how this stance became popularised,
this appears to be in large part thanks to
an 18th century prize fighter called Daniel
Mendoza.
Before Mendoza, boxing matches tended to consist
of two men more or less beating on each other
in any way possible until one of them couldn’t
get up anymore.
These matches were more of a show of manliness
and brute strength than the subtle art that
would soon develop.
Investing too much effort in defending yourself
or even taking the complete “coward’s”
way out and attempting to full on duck and
dodge regularly wasn’t something the fighters
really did.
That’s not to say they put no thought into
defence- as mentioned, keeping two arms outstretched
was a classic stance of the period- it’s
just that Mendoza took it to a whole new level.
daniel_mendozaHis style developed out of necessity,
Mendoza stood at only 5 ft. 7 in.
(1.7 m) and about 160 pounds (73 kg) in a
time when boxing was invariably dominated
by the biggest and strongest men.
But thanks to his “scientific” approach
to boxing, Mendoza in turn dominated opponents
with relentlessly sneaky offence combined
with heavy emphasis on not just blocking blows,
but slip and dodging them as well- essentially
he floated like a butterfly and stung like
a bee before it was cool.
While many accused him of being a coward for
fighting this way, the results spoke for themselves;
the little man, despite being much smaller
than most of his opponents, became the Heavyweight
Champion of England from 1792 to 1795- a true
to life David vs. Goliath personification,
making Mendoza exceptionally popular with
the masses.
Mendoza was only finally defeated owing to
his hair.
In a match against John Jackson who was a
full 4 inches taller and over 40 pounds heavier
than Mendoza, Jackson managed to grab Mendoza
by the hair and then proceeded to, ironically
enough, continually punch him in the face
with his free hand while the other kept a
firm grip on the hair, ultimately knocking
Mendoza out.
Nevertheless, Mendoza’s famed career culminated
in him quite literally writing the book on
“scientific” boxing technique.
Published in 1792, The Art of Boxing touts
the benefits of counter punching and a solid
defence:
It must be an invariable rule to stop or parry
your adversary’s right with your left, and
his left with your right; and both in striking
and parrying, always keep your stomach guarded,
by barring it with your right or left fore-arm.
jackThis is advice it would seem most every
notable boxer after Mendoza’s time took
to heart, as most boxers pictured after his
reign invariably were shown holding one hand
protectively close to their body and the other
outstretched.
Prior to this, as previously mentioned, champions
such as Jack Broughton were idealised in drawings
holding both hands away from the body, leaving
the abdomen somewhat exposed.
With the introduction of gloves in actual
matches thanks largely to the Queensberry
rules (before this gloves were mostly just
used in training), boxing forms evolved, with
the emphasis of the modern stance being protecting
the head from the gloved fist.
Old traditions die hard, however, and for
a period in the early 20th century, despite
that bare knuckled bouts had been phased out,
boxers continued to pose like old timey prize
fighters for publicity stills, even though
they now fought using a different style.
The longest known boxing fight in history
took place in New Orleans on Apr. 6, 1893,
between Andy Bowen and Jack Burke.
The fight was for the lightweight world title
and lasted 111 rounds!
After seven hours of brutal fighting, when
the bell sounded for the 111th round, both
fighters – dazed and exhausted- refused
to come out of their corners and the referee
ruled the bout as a no contest.
So yes, after 111 rounds of using their bodies
as punching bags, the contest ended in a tie.
Jack Marles, a London dentist, introduced
the first mouth guard for boxers in 1902.
At first, the safety measure to protect a
fighter’s teeth and mouth was used only
in training sessions.
It wasn’t until 1913 that the first boxer
wore one in an official fight.
It didn’t take long for mouthpieces to catch
on among boxing to reduce injuries to the
teeth and mouth.
In the 1999 film “The Hurricane,” starring
Denzel Washington, the 1964 world championship
bout between Rubin Carter and the former world
middleweight champion, Joey Giardello, is
portrayed such that Carter clearly won, but
the racist judges ruled that Giardello won
the match, becoming the world champion.
However, the truth was that Giardello, a member
of both the International Boxing Hall of Fame
and World Boxing Hall of Fame, dominated that
fight and won fair and square.
In a CNN interview shortly after the film’s
release, Carter himself discussed this and
confirmed that Giardello was the rightful
victor of the match, despite what was shown
in the movie.
This creative liberty taken by the film makers
resulted in Giardello suing them.
They ultimately settled out-of-court with
Giardello for an undisclosed sum.